- What's up, Believe Nation?
I need your help in
picking the next Top 10's
that are coming out on the channel,
and this is the video where
you can leave your requests.
So, we've done hundreds of
Top 10's on this channel,
hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds, maybe thousands.
I'll have to see how many
we've done for Top 10's.
And most of them now have
been coming from you guys,
from your feedback,
and when you're leaving
comments on different videos,
we collect them.
We start adding up who's getting
the most number of votes.
And we're at the point
where we have 2,000 to 3,000
more requests that are in our backlog,
and I want to make it easier for everybody
to help pick the next Top 10's.
So, here's what we're going to do.
This is the video that we're
going to pick the Top 10's from.
If you have somebody that
you would like to vote for
to see a next Top 10
or a Top 10 Volume Two,
maybe Volume Three or beyond,
leave it down in the comments below,
and what we're going to do
is the ones that have the most thumbs ups,
the ones that get voted up the most,
are going to be the ones
that we look at next
for making a Top 10 on the channel.
And so, instead of leaving comments
all over the different
videos on the channel,
this is the single video
where all the comments will be aggregated.
This is the one that
we're paying attention to.
So, leave the comments down,
whoever you want to see a next Top 10 on
or Volume Two, Three, Four,
Five, wherever we get to,
and if you see ones that you like,
give it a thumbs up, give it a vote
because those are going to
be the ones that rise up
and we're going to pick to do them next.
So, thank you for your support.
I'm super curious to see
how this challenge goes,
and I look forward to seeing
who you guys want to see next
in the Top 10 series.